أنا أفهم الصدمة الخاصة بك ولكن ما لا أفهمه
الفهم هو رد فعلك بعد ذلك الواعي 7
أكتوبر ورد إسرائيل سيدتي
من المحتمل أن يكون السفير لوس
غير متناسب وواضح
جريمة حرب
أنت في الواقع تشن هجمات أم
الذي تعرفه جيدًا
قتل المدنيين الأبرياء، وهناك
لا عذر لأكثر من 4000
لقد قُتل أطفال بالفعل على يد الإسرائيليين
الهجوم على 4000
هاه لذلك ربما بلدي الأول
أسألك كم عدد الأطفال كم
ولم يموت الأطفال الفلسطينيون بعد
5000 10000 50000 طفل فلسطيني
قبل أن تتوقف بلدك عن فعل ذلك
التفجيرات ليس هناك سبب على الإطلاق
لقصف عائلة للحصول على
المستشفى تحت النار
في الواقع ليست المرة الأولى، سيدتي
السفير أن المواطنين بشكل جماعي
تقع ضحية للهجمات
التفجيرات، كان عليه أن يكون
مجموع الحرب البشعة جدا ضد الجميع
الفلسطينيين لتبرير أين
لا ينبغي أن تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
مع القانون الدولي وأغتنم
يحيط علما بذلك ولكن لا أستطيع
أفهم أنني لا أستطيع أن أفهم ذلك أيضًا
إسرائيل كدولة ديمقراطية تفعل شيئا من هذا القبيل
أعتقد أنه خفيف في إسرائيل
من الصعب حاليا العثور عليه، وإذا كنت بالفعل
زملائي هنا في اللجنة
إذا استمعت للجميع
التدخلات فأنت في الواقع
دعم هذه الحرب الرهيبة بالفعل
أستطيع أن أقول أيضا أن إيه
في رأيي، لم تكن هناك مثل هذه الحرب من قبل
سوف يؤدي إلى الإسرائيليين و
الفلسطينيون آمنون، وهذا هو الحال
لن يؤدي إلى واحدة مستدامة
السلام الدائم فقط هو الذي سيفعل
يؤدي إلى السلامة والازدهار في
المنطقة بأكملها لديهم عدد من الأسئلة حول
الحرب التي تشنها ماذا ترى
في الواقع مثل Horizon قبل تلك الحرب
متى سيتوقف العنف أخيراً؟
كم عدد الضحايا الفلسطينيين؟
لا يزال هناك يسقط كحكومة إسرائيلية
في الواقع لا توجد خطة على الإطلاق لذلك
لا تزال حرة بطريقة سليمة
الحصول على ذلك ليس في مصلحة
الرهائن ما تفعلونه الآن
يفعلون ذلك وأنا أوافق فعلا
أريد أن أسمع كيف ترى ذلك مع هذا واحد
التفجيرات كل يوم
تحدث عن كيفية أخذ هؤلاء الرهائن الـ 240
لا يزال بإمكانه الحصول على حرية من هو هناك
لا شك أنهم حاضرون في هذه اللحظة
لقد مات الكثير في هذه الأثناء نحن
لا يمكن تجاهل ذلك، وهناك كله
العالم الغربي ينظر إلى هذا وذاك
كانوا حلفاءك وأنت كل منهما
يوم خاسر في الهجوم
ولا يمكن لحماس أن تؤدي إلى ذلك أبداً
الآلاف من الأطفال الأطفال الأبرياء
يموت أن مرافقي الطبية
سوف يهاجم بوحشية ذلك بلدي
وسويت المباني السكنية بالأرض وقصفت المدارس
تتسطح والأمم المتحدة تقصف الولايات المتحدة
الأمم ستهاجم مساعدات غزة
فيني ماتين دانسو دي
لا Bon Dropp Atoc et de Tuer des Civil
et des enfants c'est inac
Massad si Vous CE Qui pass Le octobre
est in مقبول et inji Il faudra
Alors Vous remettre en question eter ce
que Vous faites aujourd'hui avec d' Gaz
هو أيضا incept وآخرون
في هذه الحالة، أنت مرحب بك في convo que
Vous Pré lesقصف أكثر
عذرًا، هذا هو الحال بالنسبة لـ cisme parce que au
على العكس من ذلك preuv que Nous avons c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas des informations
Qui Tomb du ciel هو الوكالات
officiel de l'on Qui Le disent c'est
Qu'il y a des convo humanique des
سيارات الإسعاف Qui sont visé par des
قصف أت
expr de man fa prit des convis Human des
convis سيارة إسعاف donc qu Vous Nous dit
ما الذي تحتاجه للتحويل هو الرسالة
[موسيقى]
Massad par que que Vous faites c'est une
الدفاع على peut pas se
dender وmett وPlace ou ومقدم الطلب
جرائم الحرب الخاصة بالشعب
التغذية هي جريمة حربية خاصة
مجموعة من الناس هي جريمة حربية
Private Un peuple de se soigner est Un
جريمة حرب لقد قمت بقتلك قبل ذلك
الدرج
Moitié des Hux غزة Qui sont aujourd'hui
قريبا جدا يتم تشغيله
Vous AZ détruit La moitié des écoles
غزة هي أكثر عملية
الجرائم الحربية الحالية
Vous venez jus cesقصف etes atr
Ici dans CE برلمان je trouve ça
الطلب مقبول